if you were to say whatever applies in a  as a competitive advantage in any market  right any industry  what's what step would you go through  for yourself to say here's how to be  extremely having an edge in an industry  what would you say to the audience here  i would say learn the market  learn from your failures  never repeat your failures  work with people that are smarter than  you  listen  and mentally know you're the best  if you mentally know you're the best no  one can compete with you  you know me and him had a  me and the boss man had a  he asked me a question shaq there's some  guys that have to make 200 calls and  then there's other guys that have to  make 60 calls i said i really don't want  to answer that question because i don't  want to lead people down the wrong path  but i can say  the ones that are mentally strong always  get the job done